hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and we are in
round 12 of our coverage of the 2021
candidates tournament race to see who
will face magnus cross and later this
year for the world
championship this tournament does have
14 rounds so including today
there are three rounds left they do have
a day off tomorrow and then they'll come
back for the final two rounds but round
12
is extremely important and we do have
some big matchups
our matchup today we're going to be
going over could not be more significant
white's going to be played by fabiana
caruana he won this tournament a few
years ago
his opponent aneesh geary playing the
black pieces probably has the best
shot at eclipsing yon nepo for first
place right now but fabiano if he gets a
victory here
string along a couple victories in his
last two games and he could see himself
at the top of the table so we'll go
ahead and get into it
fabiano starts out with e4 we see the
sicilian
pawn c5 and then f3
pawn to e6 and we see exchange in the
center of the board and then we get into
the four nights variation in the
sicilian which we don't
see all that often and then pawn to a3
so immediately
fabiano going for something not the main
line usually
in the four night variation you see
knight to
b5 putting a lot of pressure on this d6
square right here
uh when you know the knight can come
here to d6
checking the king can't really do
anything about that so usually the
bishop takes the queen comes up here and
takes here on d6
it's kind of an awkward position so
usually d6 from black here
bishop to f4 potentially pawn e5
really forcing the bishop to g5
pinning that knight and the knight comes
back here to a3 but said you know we're
not going to be dealing
with that we're going to try something
else we're going to play pawn here to a3
bishop here e7 bishop to e3
and then bishop here to e2 you can see
usually after bishop to e3 you usually
see queen 2 d2 preparing to castle on
the queen side bishop to e2 right after
kind of leaves the door open fabiano can
either castle on the queen
or the king side uh kind of up to him
depending on how black continues here
pawn to
d6 for the the main theme that you'll
see from black standpoint in the four
knights
variation queen here to d3 so to prepare
on the queen side if he wants to
bishop to d7 and then pawn to f4 so
pretty aggressive could have just
castled on the king side had some
kingside safety with these pawns
decides to go for the aggressive
approach and
knowing that fabiano really needs a
victory here and at least
one more potentially two more for the
rest of the tournament sometimes you
have to wonder if the variations that
he's choosing
are knowing that he has to get a victory
he can't play
uh drollish at all which is from a fan
standpoint
always fun to see because these players
are going after it so
pawn to f4 definitely the aggressive
approach
and then pawn to e5
fabiano takes the knight here on c6 pawn
recaptures on c6 and you can see that
this does
open up for an attack on the queen side
there's a semi-open file
that the rook can come here to beat an
attack you could even see that the queen
get involved into the game with b6
attacking the pawn
or even the queen to c7 and then swing
the
f rook over here to b8 as well so a lot
going on here
now fabiano has kind of a choose your
own adventure as far as how he wants to
continue he could
just play rook over here to f1 not
worrying about castling right now
could just take this pawn here maybe
after the exchange he castles on the
queen side definitely dangerous
has to worry about all these threats we
just talked about but on the flip side
this is a open file that the queen and
rook are already on here
he can swing his other rook here to f1
he has both his bishops he can start to
attack on the queen or the king side of
the board
he has a pretty strong attack and if he
wants to play aggressive that definitely
could be an approach he decides to go
for what i consider
more of the safer option and instead of
taking here on e5 right away just
decides to castle on the king side but
you can see after the pawn takes bishop
takes on f4
things are still opening up there's
going to be fireworks
uh this rook here semi-open file and
after the bishop to e6
queen over here to g3 both the bishop
and the queen attacking this pawn here
on
d6 and after knight to d7 rook to
d1 so fabiano getting all of his pieces
involved into the action
both of these rooks are in semi-open
files which is definitely where you want
your rooks to be
open files are semi-open files meaning
that there's no at least one pawn
gone so that gives them room to breathe
really attack but you can also see this
rook here on d1
white has the bishop the queen and the
rook here on
d1 all attacking this pawn here
on d6 i see rook here 2e8
and then king 2h1 and really the threat
that fabiano is looking at is okay
the queen can just come down here to b6
and that's gonna check the king here on
g1
and then just take that pawn here on
b2 so decides okay let's go ahead and
get the king out of harm's way king to
h1
and then queen to b8 now if you start to
calculate how many pieces are attacking
this black is definitely down you have
the bishop the queen and the rook all
attacking this pawn and it's defended by
just one bishop and a queen but this
queen over here on b8
also attacks the pawn on b2 so if there
was an exchange maybe bishop to
d6 bishop takes rook takes the queen
could just come down here to
b2 uh and then just threatening all this
other material here on the queen side
just not really as strong as white would
really want to so decides okay yes
does have the upper hand on this d6 pawn
but decides to go ahead and play
pun up here to b4 first
niche continues with knight to e5 pawn
up here to
b5 we see rook to c8 pawn takes
rook takes here on c6 and then up here
at d5 it's an outpost but definitely
pretty easy to
remove that if black wants to queen over
here to
f8 just hiding down on this pawn here on
uh d6 pawn here to c3 i think
c3 or c4 make a lot of sense here
but this isolated pawn as we talked
about on this e file
all of a sudden now white has four pawn
structures and these isolated pawns
can be easy pickings for black to really
attack and that's exactly what he does
brings his rook over here to c8 double
barreling
the rooks here on the c file eventually
just trying to put too much pressure on
his opponent here on c3 rook to c1
protecting that a little bit knight here
to g6
bishop comes back d2 trying to protect
that which hey always good when you are
forcing your opponent to play some
defense here bishop down h4 attacking
the queen
queen two e3 rook two c5
attacking the knights right here pawn up
here c4 adding a level of
protection here and then we see the pawn
two h6 just opening up for the king if
it ever needed to
come over here to the h file you don't
have to worry about some back rank make
or anything
like that also does stop some threats if
black is ever worried about some
material coming here to the
g5 square queen over here to b3
and then bishop to g5
bishop takes pawn takes and i think this
is a pretty good
approach from black standpoint because
can bring a rook over here to the
h file and really start to attack
this king here on h1 so something to
think about for the rest of the game
queen 2 g3 queen over here to
d8 defending the pawn here on a g5
that's under attack here
rook 2 d1 and now we see the bishop take
here on
d5 and i really like this continuation
that aneesh giri found here is he
recognized that he wants to bring his
knight to f4 this is a great outpost
you can see it's on a dark square and so
the light squared bishop for white
cannot
ever take it and so he decides you know
normally you don't want to give up a
bishop for a knight especially when it's
kind of an
open board the bishop can roam the
entire board freely
but he decides that outpost is gonna be
extremely valuable so bishop takes pawn
takes here
and then knight two f4 you can see
really difficult to remove this
a pawn could potentially come up here to
a g3 but that exposes the king a little
bit more
the lights grow bishop here on e2 it can
never move it away
and so you're really looking at is the
rook gonna
take this and just give up material
probably not so this is gonna be a huge
problem that fabiano has to deal with
the rest of the game
now queen comes back to f2 we have
rook to c7 rook up here to d4
queen to e8 and you can see now the
knights
and the queen are both attacking this
bishop here on
e2 now this bishop it's defending this
pawn here on
c4 both rooks here are attacking this
pawn here this bishop is defending it
can't just come here to d3 because then
it would just fall and then after the
rook takes okay you're just giving up a
easy pawn
here uh and your rook here on c7 is
still defending this pawn here on a7
part of the reason that the queen here
on f2 is to
uh also attack this pawn here on a7
uh after the exchanges you know fabiano
is always thinking about what happens
with the exchanges
and you can't really just play rook 2e1
to protect this because rook 2e7
adds another layer of attack on this
e2 square and things get really
complicated you probably need to bring
your rook back here to d2
but then fabian just playing defense now
rook to
e3 attacking the pawn over here uh maybe
pawn a4 get it out of harm's way
queen 2 e4 attacking this pawn right
here
king to g1 things get pretty difficult
rook takes here on c4
if the bishop does take okay rook takes
on e1
now the bishops come back here pawn to
g4
you can see this is very very difficult
for white and is just trying to hold on
for dear life so in the game that's not
what we see
instead of uh rook 2e1
we see fabiano play bishop to f3 but
that opens up
since that bishop was defending it for
the rook to just come down to
c4 now rook takes rook takes and that
rook on c7 was defending the pawn on a7
so it does allow fabiano which is what
he was calculating
to play rook to a7 anish kiri playing at
the top of his game right now i think
also found the move rook to a4 so not
just sure if he found
just one move further in the calculation
uh but this is a
great find because the rook is protected
by the queen here
queen is forced to move here and after
the queen comes back you can see the
rook takes
the pawn here on a three so going into
the
end game black is up a pawn and material
and all the pawns are on one side of the
board typically when that happens the
knight
is going to fare better than a bishop a
bishop would really like pawns on both
sides of the board
because the bishop can control the
entire board but then i can control one
side of the board
extremely well pawn up here to a h4
queen down to e5 pawn takes
queen over here takes here on at g5 rook
to e1
rook up here to a8 bishop to
e4 and i think that's a mistake rick
comes down here to a
two i i think it's probably just best to
play f5 here
uh just puts black in a pretty tough
spot here but that's fine
uh bishop to e4 rook down here a2
attacking the queen and really the the
threat here is if the queen takes
uh well then the queen can just come
over here attack
the king and should have a pretty big
attack going on here you could see you
know queen
two h4 uh and then can gobble up this
rook here on
e1 uh and then just really start to
gobble up the rest of the material
after you know check and then it takes
this bishop here on e4 so that that's
really the threat here
uh fabiano is not going to fall for that
plays rook here 2b1
rook comes back to a8 rook over here to
e1 and then pawn to f5 so this
not only attacks the bishop here on e4
but after the bishop comes back then
kind of that key
move which which is what f5 was setting
up
and that is king to f7
and the reason king to f7 is so powerful
has nothing to do with king's safety
he's not worried about the rook coming
up here and he wants to be closer to the
e-file
none of that all it's doing is preparing
for the rook to come over here to the h
file and attack
the king and you can see what threat
does white really have on the king on f7
not really a whole lot where anish has a
ton of threats
on the white king so rook 2 e3
just trying to find some sort of defense
trying to get the rook involved into the
game
rook over here to h8 king 2 g1
but then the devastating move knight to
g2
and in this spot we do see fabiano
resign
just recognizing yeah there's no way to
really stop this the knight's going to
move it is going to be a discovered
attack
and things are just going to fall so
nice little deflection he's setting up
here you know you could see
queen takes here on f5 check
and yes the queen is defended by the
bishops you can say okay well after the
queen takes here
the bishop takes but then you can see
the knight takes here
on e3 and then you have a knight and a
rook
versus the bishop this is going to be a
pretty easy in game so after the knight
takes here on g2 a fantastic finishing
move
by anish kiri he gets the victory as the
black pieces now
for those wondering how the other games
went yan did win his game as well so
you know he was kind of hoping that john
would tie or lose he could actually go
into first place or at least
be for a high as far as points are
concerned
uh but he's still half a point back of
yawn since juan
john continues to dominate the field
here
uh and it it seems like an each gear is
the only one that's going to be able to
catch him so the last two games are
going to be
pivotable pivotal excuse me and anish is
playing at the top of his game so if he
can get two victories it puts a lot of
pressure on
the top spot there it's going to be fun
to watch for sure
definitely excited that all these
players almost need victories and so
they're playing a style of chess that
i'm not used to seeing in some of these
tournaments
usually see these drawlish slugfest but
it is just wide open
people are taking the most aggressive
lines they can find and it is
it is fireworks um there were there were
four victories today so four games
happened today and there was a victory
in every single game not one draw today
that's the type of chess we're seeing
it's exciting to see uh chess is better
for it i think from a fan perspective so
thank you guys so much for watching
definitely enjoyed the games today
and i will see you guys in two days they
are taking a break tomorrow
i'll see you in two days for round 13.